le piège Nord Stream que vous
décortiquez minute par minute et dans
lequel j'espère nous ne tomberons plus
on va en parler directement pendant 20
ans Vladimir Poutine a avancé ses pions
pour rendre toutes l'Europe accro à son
gaz comment la faute à qui et les
mandrée réponse dans lévitation de
Marion Becker et on en parle juste après
toutes les deux
si on vous invite Marion vonnerait un
Game c'est parce que vous venez de
publier une biographie d'un genre
nouveau embrossant le portrait d'un
tuyau qui a empoisonné l'Europe Nord
Stream vous dévoilez à travers lui une
incroyable saga ce piège tendu à
l'Europe par Vladimir Poutine au service
des intérêts économiques et
géopolitiques de la Russie Marion van
rétergem vous connaissez bien l'Europe
centrale pour y avoir mené différentes
enquêtes journalistes d'investigation
indépendante depuis quelques années
après avoir longtemps collaboré au monde
vous avez reçu le Prix Albert Londres
dans ce pôle large géopolitique ou
grouille des espions du KGB ou les morts
suspectent se comptent par dizaines ou
le mystère des deux sabotages de North
stream en septembre 2022 restant entier
vous détaillez comment Vladimir Poutine
à tisser son piège pour rendre l'Europe
dépendante et otage du gaz russe grâce à
ces deux immenses gazoducs qui relient
la Russie à l'Allemagne via la mer
Baltique
un vrai traquenard dans lequel sont
tombées nos dirigeants complices et
aveugles comme dira Schroder Angela
Merkel et François Fillon
et avec tous les représentants des pays
européens qui sont ici
nous montrons que nous comptons sur une
relation sûre et de confiance avec la
Russie s'en est même un excellent
exemple
chacun sort donc gagnant de ce
partenariat économique l'inauguration de
ce gazoduc annonçait la funeste guerre
en Ukraine alors on a une question pour
vous Marion vanreterghem aujourd'hui
ont-ils ouvert les yeux et tirez les
leçons de ce piège Nord Stream
réponse
oui et si j'en crois en tout cas les
personnalités allemandes que j'ai
rencontrées au plus haut niveau j'ai
beaucoup parlé avec Angela Merkel qui
qui est un peu un cas à part parce
qu'elle ne rentre pas dans toutes les
dans les cases de nid de la corruption
ni de la naïveté dit de la complaisance
vraiment c'est plutôt elle agit en
pragmatique dans la conséquence de
l'arrêt du nucléaire il y a beaucoup à
en dire j'ai fait j'ai la complicité
l'aveuglement la cupidité la faiblesse
tout ça c'est derrière nous aujourd'hui
malheureusement je ne pense pas parce
que on a encore le problème chinois qui
se pose et malgré tout on est on est on
a tendance à se prendre au piège des
grandes puissances alors la Chine n'a
pas tendu un piège aussi méthodiquement
pendant de 20 ans comme l'a fait
Vladimir Poutine mais je ne suis pas sûr
qu'on soit totalement vacciné dans mon
livre j'interview très longuement le
ministre de l'Économie l'ancien ministre
de l'Économie d'Angela Merkel
social-démoc qui faisait partie de la
coalition Sigmar Gabriel zigmar Gabriel
et qui ce n'était pas mon intention en
allant le voir mais j'étais tellement
frappé par cette interview tellement si
clairvoyante je n'ai jamais vu en France
l'équivalent d'un homme ou d'une femme
politique parlé avec autant de netteté
de son erreur de l'autocritique dans
l'autocritique je dois dire que du coup
j'en ai fait une longue interview dans
le livre parce que là on
reproduit un peu finalement ce que
m'avait dit aussi Angela Merkel et
d'autres que j'ai sur le fait qu'il y
avait quand même quelque chose qui n'ont
pas vu et c'est ce qui n'ont pas vu
c'était cette appétit territoriale de
Vladimir alors justement vous parlez
l'une des plus des gigantesques les plus
gigantesques erreurs stratégiques du 21e
siècle c'est voilà c'est très fort comme
formule c'est avant tout pour vous
l'erreur de qui est-ce que c'est
l'Occident dans son ensemble de l'Europe
avant tout de l'Allemagne principalement
bonne question je pense que c'est une
erreur extrêmement collective européenne
à l'exception de ceux qui ont vu clair
c'est-à-dire les pays baltes la Pologne
l'Ukraine qui n'était pas encore dans
l'Union européenne les plus coupables ce
sont les plus
ostensiblesment coupables sont les
Allemands parce que c'est une grande
puissance industrielle la première
puissance économique européenne et que
du fait qu'ils ont fait du nucléaire un
tabou c'est une histoire en soi ça la
manière dont ils sont venus au tabou du
nucléaire mais étant une grande
puissance ayant renoncé et la population
dans son ensemble ne voulant pas
entendre parler du nucléaire ne pouvant
pas utiliser le charbon comme il le
voudrait vu les besoins écologiques de
la planète ils se sont rués sur le
gâteau et que il y a le il y a la
solution du gaz russe bon marché donc
eux ce sont les principaux
coupables si l'on peut dire mais les
Français leurraient été autant s'ils
n'avaient pas eu le nucléaire et on ne
peut pas dire que les Français ont
condamné les Allemands et d'ailleurs les
compétences françaises sont présentes
a insisté pour pour cela Nicolas Sarkozy
avait vendu des navires Mistral à la
Russie on peut imaginer si François
Hollande n'avait pas stoppé ces
mistrales il serait parti prenant dans
la guerre contre l'Ukraine on aurait on
serait dans de beaudra donc ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est les Allemands
sont sont les premiers rang mais malgré
tout il y a eu assez collective en
dehors des pays de l'Est qui étaient qui
connaissaient la Russie mieux que les
autres et en dehors des Américains qui
pour des intérêts personnels mais aussi
par lucidité ont toujours alerté le
danger contre cette dépendance qui est
fascinant dans le livre au-delà des
scènes qui sont restituées entre Moscou
Berlin c'est comme si on était présent
c'est que le projet Nord Stream déjà
correspond à l'arrivée de Vladimir
Poutine au pouvoir et vous dites et vous
démontrez que déjà il avait dans la tête
l'Ukraine ça c'est très important que
vous soulignez ça parce qu'en effet ce
qui m'a frappé c'est que en prenant ce
Nord Stream comme un personnage en fait
une espèce de fil conducteur de cette
grande histoire de dépendance entre la
Russie et l'Europe je me suis rendu
compte et à chaque fois j'étais étonné
par les coïncidences de dates que en
fait la durée de vie de North stream
correspond totalement de du début à la
fin parce qu'il est toujours là mais à
la durée de vie de Poutine au pouvoir et
c'est immédiatement après être arrivé au
pouvoir en 2000 en 2000 qu'en 2001
l'idée de Nord Stream est lancé par
Vladimir Poutine alors justement s'y
connaît en matière première et dans le
rôle des matières premières sur une pour
bâtir une grande puissance puisqu'il
avait fait une thèse plagiée mais signée
par lui sur l'importance des matières
premières dans la puissance d'un pays
justement tout commence il y a 20 ans
lors d'un discours resté dans les
mémoires en Allemagne le jeune Poutine
vient d'arriver au pouvoir donc et il
choisit Berlin pour l'une de ses
premières visites à l'étranger on va
l'écouter dans un Allemand quasi parfait
s'adresser aux députés allemands
alors la guerre froide est finie ses
glaçons d'ailleurs quand on connaît la
suite vous racontez ça dans le détail là
c'est l'opération séduction de Poutine
qui fonctionne à merveille oui on voit
il a l'air tout à fait inoffensif il y a
une innovation debout au parlement
allemand les seuls qui sont réservés et
le seul parti qui a toujours été réservé
vis-à-vis de la Russie de la Chine c'est
le Parti vert allemand ce qui est
paradoxal c'est que c'est le parti est
très très opposé aux dictatures à la
dépendance à North stream ils ont
toujours sonné l'alarme mais pour autant
c'est cette idéologie anti-nucléaire qui
est le socle du Parti vert qui a
provoqué cette dépendance au gazeuse
donc là il les verres sont dans une
forme de paradoxe et au premier rang ce
discours on est en 2001 juste après
d'ailleurs l'attaque du 11 septembre il
y a des rares Schroeder tout sourire
chancelier déjà séduit totalement séduit
et au fond le premier le premier
compagnon le plus le plus investi dans
le projet Nord Stream conscient de
toutes ses conséquences exactement et ce
discours donc a lieu en 2003 juste après
l'attentat du 11 septembre contre les
tours du de Manhattan ce qui explique
aussi une forme de complicité c'est que
tout le monde est dans le même combat
contre l'islamisme Poutine en a fait une
raison d'être avec sa guerre en
Tchétchénie et il a fauté de faux
attentats Moscou en accusant les
tchétches enfin il est dans une guerre
contre l'islamisme là il rejoint
l'Occident et donc tout l'Occident
a-t-on et apprécie l'arrivée de Vladimir
Poutine qui d'autant plus qu'il tranche
avec le président son prédécesseur
boricelsin qui faisait peur à tout le
monde parce que c'était un gros Soulard
qui dansait sur les tables que il avait
l'air de son pays était en véritable
chaos il avait certes assuré la
transition démocratique mais tout le
monde avait peur de ce qui était en
train de devenir la Russie et donc
Poutine arrive comme une espèce de
d'espoir et et garde Schroder qui est
déjà séduit on le voit dans cette scène
au Bundes a déjà commencé à négocier
avec lui cette affaire Nord Stream c'est
déjà en germe dans leur tête c'est déjà
dans les tuyaux il va être propulsé à la
tête du consortium Nord Stream
âgé juste après son son départ de la de
la Chancellerie d'ailleurs l'enquête est
accablante pour lui mais pour beaucoup
beaucoup de dirigeants et notamment de
chefs d'entreprise du milieu économique
vous parlez de la Nord Stream connection
en Allemagne pour ce figurer les choses
je vais vous montrer le siège à
Saint-Pétersbourg de Gazprom leader
mondial du gaz c'est donc évidemment
dans la ville de Vladimir Poutine
qu'est-ce qu'elle symbolise cette image
alors c'est on pense tous à une give à
une ogive nucléaire ça n'est pas un
hasard c'est un monument c'est je crois
que c'est une des plus grandes des tours
les plus hautes du monde évidemment
Poutine a fait dans le gigantisme ce qui
est intéressant aussi c'est que donc
Poutine a voulu symboliser la puissance
de la Russie par cette tour de gaz Prom
qui est comme vous le rappeliez le plus
grand groupe gazier mondial pour le plus
grand producteur de gaz le plus grand
distributeur de gaz et ce qui n'est pas
hasard non plus c'est que Poutine a
déplacé le siège de Gazprom qui était
préalablement à Moscou vers
Saint-Pétersbourg et la ville de
Saint-Pétersbourg pour Poutine c'est
très important d'abord bon allez au bord
de la de la Baltique donc c'est de là
que va partir Nord Stream mais c'est
surtout la ville de son éducation
c'était il est né lui à Lénine grade et
il a eu deux référents deux écoles qui
étaient les venaient d'un milieu très
pauvre il fallait se démener et survivre
dans un une un milieu extrêmement
difficile sous l'airbré Genève qui était
une ville tenue par les mafia et son
école ça a été d'abord les chefs mafieux
auxquels il a réussi à justement à
s'intégrer avec plutôt brio et l'autre
école c'était le KGB et tout ça c'est sa
formation c'est sa ville natale et sont
toute sa bande d'amis qu'on appelait la
bande de Peter Saint-Pétersbourg qui
sont d'ailleurs
incroyablement Léa la bande du KGB la
bande de petersburg
simplement reclasser
recaser d'engasprom dans Nord Stream on
retrouve tous les anciens espions du KGB
c'est passionnant vous n'avez pas
rencontré
le livre mais Angela Merkel elle va
lancer enfin elle va inaugurer on a tous
les images on les a vu dans dans le
sujet le grand projet Nord Stream après
l'annexion de la Crimée comment comment
c'est possible que j'appelle dans mon
livre l'année de la honte c'est 2014 qui
est donc l'année de l'invasion de la
Crimée et là il y a quand même une
faiblesse coupable alors là c'est pas
seulement les Allemands c'est vraiment
tout l'Occident y compris les États-Unis
on condamne par des sanctions mais on
est face à quelqu'un qui très clairement
nous montre déjà il y avait mille
manières de le savoir et de le percevoir
et des journalistes ont alerté encore
une fois les pays de l'Est ont alerté
sur le fait que Poutine dès son arrivée
au pouvoir à un plan un plan d'expansion
territoriale le la stratégie l'objectif
de Poutine qui est au fond assez clair
très vite c'est de reconstituer les
frontières de l'Union soviétique dont il
a dit que la chute et le déclin était la
catastrophe la plus grande catastrophe
du 20e siècle ça il l'a dit écrit et il
veut récupérer ses propres frontières et
en tout premier lieu l'Ukraine est une
forme d'obsession chez lui en
particulier depuis 2005 et les révolu
2004 2005 et les révolutions la
Révolution orange et il veut donc
récupérer cet empire et il prend des
petits bouts il avance pas à pas la il
ne comprend que la force dès qu'il voit
un signe de faiblesse il prend un bout
de la Géorgie il prend sur de l'Ukraine
il prend
principale arme donc on revient de 2014
où là il fait un pas de plus et
l'Occident s'écrase plus ou moins mais
comme il y a aussi les incidents dans le
bomba c'est des milliers de morts il y a
ces accords de Minsk c'est des
négociations de mins qui commencent avec
le président français Hollande la
chancelière Merkel le président
ukrainien poroscenko et Vladimir Poutine
pour essayer de faire cesser ses combats
et là tout se brouille est ce que
m'avait expliqué Angela Merkel c'était
qu'on ne peut pas au moment où on
commence une négociation avec quelqu'un
pour essayer d'arrêter les combats lui
dire bah non du coup on annule ce projet
qui est celui qui te tient le plus à la
réelle politique alors bon c'est aussi
de la rangement c'est vrai que North
stream 2 il y a une prise de conscience
et vous l'expliquez bien dans le rythme
par rapport au premier pas plane petite
question quand même sur le sabotage ça
reste très mystérieux de North stream 2
qui n'était d'ailleurs pas activé alors
certains accusent l'Ukraine on a
d'autres accusent Poutine qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez il y a eu beaucoup de
scénarios et d'enquêtes depuis le début
de cette affaire à peu près tout le
monde y est passé il y a eu on a accusé
les Russes les Ukrainiens les Polonais
les Britanniques les Américains tout ça
donc il y a eu des enquêtes de des
journaux sérieux mais qui n'apportent
aucun élément probant qui qui ne repose
qui sont toutes issues les dernières du
spiggle et du Washington Post sont issus
de l'enquête allemande avec des éléments
concordants mais dont aucun
n'aboutit à un scénario définitif ce ne
sont que des hypothèses et ce que je
remarque moi c'est que personne ne part
du mauvais postulat parce que personne
ne prend en compte le fait que ce
pipeline c'est pas parce qu'il a été
saboté qu'il est détruit d'abord il a
été saboté à un moment où il n'était
déjà plus en fonction donc et où
personne ne pensait le remettre en
fonction et il en reste un bout et il en
reste tuyau il y a un tuyau sur quatre
qui est intacte et en plus il faut pas
il faut imaginer que c'est 1200 km dans
de tuyaux de de tuyaux dans la mer
Baltique les infrastructures qui coûtent
très cher sont intactes il y a 20 mètres
qui sont détruits c'est à dire c'est
extrêmement réparable ouais donc
évidemment la possibilité c'était donc
un utilisé ça peut être lui ça peut être
j'expose dans mon livre les hypothèses
je dis qu'il y a des des intérêts
rationnels et ça c'est seulement la
Russie qui est un intérêt rationnel et
il y a des intérêts passionnés à le
faire et là tout le monde est concerné
donc bon je laisse vous l'aurez compris
c'est absolument passionnant le piège
Nord Stream aussi a le temps avec je le
disais cette plume à la polar mais tout
est vrai c'est une enquête
journalistique signée Marion bonne
rotterghem que je recommande